what's going on guys Greg Aldi here so I
got into a Twitter debate with a few
people last night kg6 destiny godspeed
52 in DC fan five six five seven five
they're wanting me to do a reaction to
the flash arrow Supergirl DC legend is
tomorrow for a night crossover event
trailer I was debating with them because
I'm like I'm not going to do it I don't
want to do it because I haven't been
following the show's loyally I've only
seen up to the end of season 2 a flash
only seen season 1 of arrow haven't seen
Supergirl haven't seen DC's legends of
tomorrow so I'm not going to [ __ ] my
way through seeming like I know all this
[ __ ] and out of thought I'm like I don't
think I should do it because of that
fact it would just be a reaction and
it's going to be kind of hard to make
commentary and I feel like it's what's
given a lot of reaction channels about
rep is when you know you do a reaction
to a video that you can't really comment
on they window with enough persistent I
was like guys this video came out of
like many months ago then episodes
already premiered and I don't really
follow all the chef's you guys managed
to convince me I'll do it I'll do it
just for you three you three guys right
here or a hardcore DC fan
[Music]
I'm just watching a classic whoa what
the hell failures we've been calling in
the dominators that is not the name of
the PC that company Dominator
we must exterminate your kind before
this surge of your becomes sister down
and tremana typical your worldwide
Gary you did it
[Music]
all our 300k why'd you marry my
firestorm yeah B wait how did you get
the name t way
I've burned my family alive I like to
light things on fire our backstory seems
just that so much shorter you really get
it this Sunday in an armor no wall dude
I lost out now it's up to you to keep
our home safe
I punch them in the console you print
that bride against me here we go
Wow
what's up I have doing the budget
through
[Music]
I wish I was oh yeah sure thing
yeah I just feel so bad now because this
is this is like all the way back in
November me watching over something
that's hurdy aired I just I feel like I
just don't feel like it'd be worth
anyone's time for anyone to even watch
this video there's so much TV out there
there's so much TV out there and then it
was a couple other videos I did recently
I explained how like there's a lot of
stuff I'm working on outside of YouTube
as well you know thinking like man I got
to watch like a lot of seasons of [ __ ]
so I could really appreciate this
crossover cuz I'm not the kind of guy
who would just go and watch the
crossover you know I'm not the kind of
guy who would even if it's like the
movies I wouldn't just go watch The
Avengers or actually I know we're
watching Justice League without seeing a
bunch of solo films okay with the
Avengers I would I wouldn't miss all the
prior movies and then watch the
crossover by itself and that's how I
felt about feel about this is like if I
ever get around to watching this
crossover it will be because I watched
all the episodes from all the shows that
led up to this one episode it was
Supergirl I here is a really good show I
heard surprisingly good I really do love
the flash I'm sure in my life would be a
lot better and it would make everyone a
lot happier I just watch the flash
wanted air but I noticed my habit I've
become the thing that joss whedon
complains about it employed a binge
watch so like I was way for the season
to come out and then I'll binge watch
the entire thing
damn that that was a really cool trailer
though that trailer was really sweet I
always saw the first season of arrow I
only saw it first season I really liked
Oliver Queen I think he's a really cool
character it was just the show itself I
wasn't that drawn to the series I wasn't
that pulled into I hear it gets better
in season two I hear
it's really good I just haven't taken
the time giving it the chance that it
deserves of my viewing I really want to
catch up on the flash it's just what I
think so I get a little I can't spit a
little overwhelmed it's like four
different [ __ ] shows here that you
gotta watch in order to in order to
really truly appreciate the crossover
episodes maybe I should just do it maybe
I should just start watching I hear like
Superman and the Supergirl show is
better than Henry Cavill I've heard easy
legends of smart remember that shows all
right arrow I know that like the last
season or two has a Mego in the highest
reputation it surely is fascinating what
movie and TV is becoming what comic-book
adaptations have done for TV and film
this whole idea with like expanded
universe and crossovers it's just crazy
it's crazy
this is nuts this is insane all the
movies you got to watch to watch a
crossover movies and all these shows you
got to watch to watch a crossover show
and even a marvel sighs they got the
defenders coming out which I'm really
excited for you see like for me it's
easier for me to watch the Marvel shows
because they release that I don't watch
agents of shield III don't you know I
watched the the Netflix shows because
that's easy it's like here's all 13
episodes at once just binge watch them
it's only 13 episodes you know with a
show with these shows that you're
looking at a lot more than 13 episodes
per season but maybe I should just quit
my bitching because that's all I'm
really doing right now and all I'm doing
is making excuses for why I'm not taking
I feel I feel really lazy if I just only
watch like like that much TV and don't
try to do my own like writing on the
side or something or work on something
else on the side even though this
channel probably makes me look pretty
lazy because I'm just sitting in front
of a computer and talking about videos
for sure if I decide I was going to
binge watch all these shows if I find
out that they're gonna put like Superman
and Martian Manhunter and black
lightning or vixen Hawk girl or and
we're deceiving it like a Batman in the
CW shows I will
eventually get around to catching up on
all these shoes what's great about this
trailer that I really love is he got
like so many different characters but
they all look like they have like
dynamite chemistry together the entire
cast chemistry looks really cool this
video has led me to feel ashamed of
myself for not having seen this video
earlier and not catching up on the shows
that's that's what all you dudes on
Twitter have made me feel like now it's
shame I got homework to do
alright well that was for the people who
requested this a long time ago for the
3do to debate it with me on Twitter
about why I should still watch it even
though I haven't been following the ship
I do these videos for you guys even when
I'm kind of conflicted on whether or not
I should do it subscribe for the real
rejects buh-bye